programming throwdown episode 60 javascript for mobile take it away jason. Hey, everyone. We're here with Burke Holland, who's from Progress, and he's an expert at doing JavaScript for mobile, and he's going to kind of talk to us about that and how that whole process works. So, Burke, why don't you start by telling us sort of what you do at Progress and kind of a bit about your background. Hello. Yes. Well, first of all, thanks for having me tonight. This is really neat. I work for Progress Software, which is a public company that makes a lot of different pieces of software. I work in developer relations, so my job is to write blog posts and build tutorials and do webinars. And
Programming Throwdown 第 60 期：移动端 JavaScript，Jason，开始吧。大家好。我们今天请到了来自 Progress 的 Burke Holland，他是移动端 JavaScript 开发方面的专家，他将为我们介绍相关内容以及整个流程是如何运作的。那么，Burke，不如先向大家介绍一下你在 Progress 的工作以及你的背景。你好。好的，首先，感谢今晚邀请我。这真的很棒。我为 Progress Software 工作，这是一家上市公司，生产许多不同的软件产品。我在开发者关系部门工作，所以我的工作是撰写博客文章、制作教程和举办网络研讨会。而且
I go to a lot of events and I do podcasts way, way, way too late in the evening. Yeah. When you're doing the folks at home, when you're doing those tutorials, when you look up some new tool or some cool new technique, and you're learning about how to use it, and you're following the step-by-step tutorial, it's written by Burke or someone like him. That's correct. All of them, yes. Even if it's not my name, it's a ghostwriter. That's correct.
我经常参加各种活动，而且我做播客的时间总是太晚太晚了。是的。当你在做那些教程时，对于在家里的听众朋友们，当你查找某个新工具或某种很酷的新技术，并且在学习如何使用它，然后按照分步教程操作时，这些教程都是由 Burke 或像他这样的人编写的。没错。全都是，是的。即使上面没有我的名字，也是代笔写的。没错。
That's right. Totally accurate. I've made an Android app a long time ago, and it was really bad. I mean, the idea was good, but I realized that that's kind of a special skill, and with absolutely no training, the app was just constantly crashing, or you'd hit a button, it'd kind of freeze up. And it was very hard to debug.
就是这样。完全准确。我很久以前做过一个 Android 应用，真的很糟糕。我的意思是，想法是好的，但我意识到这是一种特殊的技能，而且在完全没有培训的情况下，应用总是不断崩溃，或者你点击一个按钮，它就会卡住。而且调试起来非常困难。
I just didn't really know what I was doing. So for people like us who might have done some programming on the console, maybe built a website, done things like that, how is mobile development kind of different? Yeah, that's a great question. And just sort of to baseline this, my background was originally as a web developer, but I ended up doing a lot of C sharp, because that was just the environment that I was in. So I was always in flex or something like that on the front end or web, you know, but then always, always C sharp. So I actually wrote an Android app way back in the day to early on. And it was like a pick a number app where you would just pick a number between one and 10 and it would tell you if you were wrong or right. Oh, nice. Mine was very similar. I published it to the store. Mine was a trivia app where it just,
我当时真的不知道自己在做什么。所以对于像我们这样可能在控制台做过一些编程，或者建过网站，做过类似事情的人来说，移动开发有什么不同呢？是的，这是一个很好的问题。为了打好基础，我的背景最初是 Web 开发人员，但我最终做了很多 C# 开发，因为那是我所处的环境。所以我总是在前端或 Web 上使用 Flex 之类的东西，你知道，但总是，总是 C#。所以我确实在很久以前写过一个 Android 应用。那是一个“猜数字”应用，你只需要选择一个 1 到 10 之间的数字，它会告诉你猜对了还是猜错了。哦，不错。我的非常相似。我把它发布到了商店里。我的是一个问答应用，它只是，
it asked you a bunch of multiple choice questions and then it just told you if you were right or not. And even that, it was hard to do. Right, I think yours was actually way better than mine. Mine was terrible. And I put it out in the app store for like 99 cents and i thought for sure i would be a millionaire but to this day to this day i get emails from google wallet telling me that i need there's not enough in
它问你一堆选择题，然后告诉你是否答对了。即使是这样，也很难做到。对，我觉得你的其实比我的好多了。我的太糟糕了。我把它以 99 美分的价格放到了应用商店里，我以为我肯定会成为百万富翁，但直到今天，直到今天，我还会收到 Google Wallet 的邮件，告诉我我的账户里钱不够，他们无法支付给我，因为至少需要十美元，所以这就像，我知道，这有多可悲啊。呃，所以是的，嗯，你知道，过去五年里变化很大，但它通常不仅需要了解一种语言，还需要了解一个非常具体的操作系统，以及该操作系统之上的一套 SDK。所以对于 iOS 来说，那将是，你知道，Cocoa Touch 之类的东西，UIKit，诸如此类。然后在 Android 方面，你显然拥有所有的 Android SDK，以及随之而来的 Java。然后在 iOS 方面，是 Objective-C，现在是 Swift，这真的很棒。
my account for them to pay me because it needs to be at least ten dollars so it's been like i know it's how sad is that uh so yeah um, you know, has changed a lot in the past five years, but it generally requires knowing not just a language, but also a very specific operating system and then set of SDKs on top of that operating system. So for iOS, that would be, you know, the Cocoa Touch stuff, UIKit, things like that. And then on the Android side, you obviously have all the Android SDKs and then Java that goes along with that. And then on the iOS side, Objective-C and now Swift, which is really nice.
明白了。那么你是怎么，我的意思是，如果你正在运行一个程序，你在做学校的作业或者类似的事情，你知道，他们教给你的事情之一就是调试器，你通过它一步步执行，并且你在你的机器上运行它。所以这看起来非常清楚该怎么做。当你连接到手机时，你是如何进行调试和类似操作的呢？嗯，我认为这取决于你使用的工具。但我知道对于 iOS，你知道，它有 Xcode，Xcode 允许你设置断点并进行调试。
Gotcha. So how do you, I mean, if you're running a program, you're doing some assignment for school or something like that, you know, one of the things they teach you is the debugger and you kind of step through and you're running it kind of on your machine. So it seems kind of very clear how to do that. How do you do debugging and things like that when you're connected to your phone? Well, I think it depends on the tooling that you use. But I know for like iOS, you know, that has Xcode and Xcode allows you to set breakpoints and debug.
Android Studio 也是一样，对吧？它允许你在代码中设置断点，然后一步步执行并进行调试。所以这两个不同的平台，你知道，我们谈论的是两大巨头，对吧？
And the same thing with Android Studio, right? Which allows you to put breakpoints into your code and then to step through and debug. So both of the different platforms, you know, we're talking about the big two, right?
通常免费提供工具。我认为 Xcode 是免费的，Android Studio 对人们进入并开始进行移动开发也是免费的。现在也有很多培训。iOS 有大量的培训，Android 也有大量的免费培训。所以开发者很容易上手。所以他们拥有如此成熟的工具，感觉就像你在桌面上调试一样，你可以一步步执行代码并设置断点。但是手机之间的来回切换对你来说是完全不透明的。它只是能用。绝对是这样。这是一个很好的观点。是的，
Offer tooling, usually free of charge. I think Xcode's free, Android Studio is free as well for people to get into and start doing mobile development. And now there's a lot of training as well. There's a ton of training for iOS, a ton of free training for Android out there. So it's pretty easy to get your hands on the developers. So they've got the tooling so mature where it feels like you're debugging on your desktop where you can kind of step through the code and set breakpoints. But the whole going back and forth between the phone is kind of all just opaque to you. It just kind of works. Absolutely. That's a really good point. Yeah,
我们现在有这些模拟器，对吧？所以手机实际上就在桌面上，你可以模拟位置、多点触控以及几乎所有可用的设备 API。你实际上不必把它放在手机上，这使得循环，对吧？开发、测试、调试循环比原本要快得多。明白了。有道理。酷。所以，你，所以，大多数时候当你进行移动开发时，你是在用一种特定的语言编程。比如 Android，操作系统本身，很多是用 Java 编写的。所以很多 API、SDK 都在 Java 中。
that we have these emulators or simulators now, right? So the phone's actually on the desktop and you can simulate location and multi-touch and pretty much every device API that's available. You don't actually have to put it on your phone, which makes the loop, right? The develop test debug loop a lot faster than it otherwise would be. Gotcha. Makes sense. Cool. So, you So, most of the time when you do development on mobile, you're programming in a specific language. Like Android, the operating system itself, a lot of it is written in Java. And so a lot of the APIs, SDKs in Java.
所以要制作一个应用，你通常使用 Java。对于 iOS，全是 Objective-C，我想现在是 Swift。但 NativeScript 既不是其中之一，也不是任何这些。它是 JavaScript。那么这到底是怎么回事呢？是的，所以我认为对于那些试图进行移动开发的人来说，最令人沮丧的事情之一就是移动开发会让你很快感到非常无能。原因在于你确实需要了解太多东西。
And so to make an app, you typically do Java. For iOS, it's all Objective-C and I guess now Swift. But NativeScript isn't either of those, any of those. It's JavaScript. So what is that all about? Yeah, so I think one of the most frustrating things for people that are trying to do mobile development is that mobile development can make you feel very inadequate very quickly. And the reason for that is that you do have to know so much.
这不仅仅是一种语言。它也是一个操作系统。它也是一套庞大的 SDK。如果你能为一个平台掌握它，你仍然有另一个平台。我们并没有真正生活在 90 年代的旧桌面世界里，对吧？在那里你可以为 Windows 写一个应用，然后你就基本搞定了，对吧？你只是走开说，好吧，完成了。那是每个人。是的。尤其是现在。
It's not just a language. It's also an operating system. It's also a giant set of SDKs. And if you are able to master that for one platform, you still have the other platform. And we don't really live in the old desktop world of the 90s, right, where you can write an app for Windows and you're pretty much good to go, right? You just kind of walk away and be like, all right, done. That's everyone. Yeah. Especially now.
对。情况不再是这样了。所以现在，你知道，真的，如果你有一个应用只在 iOS 上可用，感觉就像真的只在 iOS 上，拜托，对吧？Android 上也是一样。所以如果你想拥有一个成功的，特别是消费者移动应用，你真的必须覆盖这两个平台。第二个原因是，今天大多数公司都有自带设备政策，对吧？所以你过去有这些严苛的移动政策，每个人都得到一个黑莓手机，你只能凑合着用，对吧？
Right. That is not the case anymore. So now, you know, really, if you have an app that's only available on iOS, feel like really only on iOS, come on, right? And the same thing on Android. So if you want to have a successful, especially consumer mobile application, you really have to hit both those platforms. And then the second one is that most companies today have bring your own device policies, right? So you used to have these draconian sort of mobility policies where everyone got a Blackberry and you just sort of dealt with it, right?
而且你没有抱怨，对吧？你只是很高兴有一部手机。你有两部、三部或四部手机，所以每个人都认为你在做一些可疑的事情。对，那是因为如果你非常重要，你周围就会有一圈黑莓手机。但现在，人们自带设备，因为它们非常个人化。所以即使你在企业工作并且在进行移动开发，
And you didn't complain, right? You're just glad to have a mobile phone. You had two or three or four phones, so everyone thought that you were doing something shady. Right, that's because if you were super important, you had like the bat belt of Blackberries going around you. But now, people bring their own devices because they're so personal. And so even if you work in an enterprise and you're doing mobile development,
你很可能不仅针对不同的操作系统，而且针对同一操作系统的不同版本。所以这真的，真的非常令人沮丧。所以 NativeScript 试图解决的问题是双重的。它试图解决的第一个问题是，它试图将一切简化为大多数人都能理解的通用语言，那就是 JavaScript。所以，你知道，JavaScript，无论你喜欢还是讨厌它，它已经存在很长时间了。它不会消失。关于它有很多不同的意见，但由于其极其宽容的特性，它是最容易学习的语言之一。而且它无处不在，对吧？所以一旦你学会了它，你就可以在 Web 上编写它。
you're likely targeting not just different operating systems, but different versions of the same operating system. So it's really, really frustrating. So the problem that NativeScript tries to solve is twofold. The first one that it tries to solve is it tries to bring everything down to a very common language that most people understand, and that's JavaScript. So, you know, JavaScript, love it or hate it, it's been around for a long time. It's not going anywhere. There's a lot of different opinions on it, but it's one of the easiest languages to learn due to its extremely forgiving nature. And it's ubiquitous, right? So once you learn it, you can write it on the web.
然后使用 NativeScript，你也可以用它创建原生移动应用。这是第一个原则。NativeScript 的第二个原则是，同一个项目应该能够在 iOS 和 Android 上运行。当你把它运行在 iOS 上时，你应该得到一个原生的 iOS 应用。当你把它运行在 Android 上时，你应该得到一个原生的 Android 应用。所有这些都应该在同一个项目中，这样你只需要学习一套工具，但你可以针对所有不同的移动平台以及这些移动平台的不同版本。我明白了。所以有一个，我想，NativeScript 运行时，如果你愿意的话，针对所有这些不同的平台，它找到某种方法将你的意图从 JavaScript 代码转换为原生体验。正是如此。这完全正确。我不知道在描述中是否有人能这么早就说中，但是
And then with NativeScript, you can also create native mobile applications with it. So that's the first tenet. And then the second one for NativeScript is that the same project should be able to run on iOS and on Android. And when you run it on iOS, you should get a native iOS app. And when you run it on Android, you should get a native Android app. And all of that should be in the same project so that you're only learning one set of tools, but that you can target all the different mobile platforms and different versions of those mobile platforms as well. I see. So there's, I guess, a NativeScript runtime, if you will, for all these different platforms, and it finds some way to translate your intent from the JavaScript code into native experience. Exactly what it is. That is exactly right. I don't know that I've had anyone nail it that early on before in the description, but
它是一个运行时。它正是如此。基本上它所做的是它采用一个虚拟机，即 JavaScript 虚拟机。对于 Android，那是 V8。对于 iOS，那是 JavaScript Core。它采用这个虚拟机。通常，如果你有一个浏览器，比如 Safari、Chrome 或 Edge，
it's a runtime. It's exactly what it is. And basically what it does is it takes a virtual machine, so a JavaScript virtual machine. So for Android, that's V8. And for iOS, that's JavaScript core. And it takes this virtual machine. And normally, if you have a browser, like Safari or Chrome or Edge,
你有一个执行所有 JavaScript 的虚拟机。然后那个虚拟机通过我们称之为 DOM 或文档对象模型的东西了解关于浏览器的所有信息，对吧？所以这允许你使用 JavaScript 实际操作页面或查询页面上的项目。所以 DOM，对于不知道的人来说，DOM 是这棵树，
you have a virtual machine that executes all the JavaScript. And then that virtual machine knows all about the browser via something that we call the DOM or the document object model, right? And so this allows you to use JavaScript to actually manipulate the page or query items on the page. So the DOM, for people who don't know, the DOM is this tree,
你实际上可以看到它。如果你去任何网站，你可以查看源代码，这，你在 Chrome 中怎么做？在 Chrome 中，你点击查看，然后开发者，然后查看源代码。你实际上会看到这个，
and you can actually see it. If you go on any website, you can do view source, which, how do you do it in Chrome? In Chrome, you go view, and then developer, and then view source. And you'll actually see this,
你知道，它只有一个 HTML 标签。那是根节点。你实际上可以向下钻取，你知道，它只有一个 HTML 标签。那是根节点。你实际上可以向下钻取。会有 head 标签和 body 标签。body 标签会有更多的标签。你在网站上看到的一切都是那种 HTML 树的一部分。这被称为 DOM。JavaScript 让你能够与它进行某种交互。
you know, it has just an HTML tag. That's the root. And you can actually drill down, you know, it has just an HTML tag. That's the root. And you can actually drill down. There'll be a head tag and a body tag. And the body tag will have more tags. And everything you see when you go on a website is part of that sort of tree of HTML. And that's called the DOM. And JavaScript lets you sort of interact with that.
是的，完全正确。我记得我刚开始学习 Web 开发时，我会读到那个词，DOM，我会想，我不知道那是什么意思。它确实就是那样。它只是页面上存在的 HTML，但它也是浏览器暴露出来的用于与之交互的不同 API，这样你就可以通过编程
Yeah, that's exactly right. And I remember when I was first learning web development, I would read that word, the DOM, and I would be, I don't know what that means. And it really is exactly that. It's just the HTML that exists on the page, but it's also the different APIs that the browser exposes to interact with that so that you can programmatically
用 JavaScript 操作页面。嗯，在 NativeScript 中，没有 HTML，对吧？因为我们不是在构建网站，我们是在构建原生移动应用。所以相反，NativeScript 所做的是，它说，好吧，这里没有浏览器，但有一个移动操作系统。所以我不使用 DOM API，我实际上要将所有的原生 API 注入到这个虚拟机中。所以这意味着一旦你在 NativeScript 运行时内部，你就可以只使用 JavaScript 调用任何原生 API。所以不像在 Web 上，你可能会做 document.getElementById，
manipulate the page with JavaScript. Well, in NativeScript, there is no HTML, right? Because we're not building websites, we're building native mobile apps. So instead, what NativeScript does, it says, okay, we don't, there's no browser here, but there is a mobile operating system. So instead of the DOM APIs, I'm actually going to inject all of the native APIs into this virtual machine. So what that means is that once you're inside the NativeScript runtime, you can call any native API just using JavaScript. So instead of doing, yeah, so on the web, you may do document.getElementById,
这会选择一个具有特定 ID 的 div。嗯，在 NativeScript 中，你可以说 var color equals uicolor.init with 无论 iOS 中的方法是什么。它实际上会给你一个原生的 iOS 颜色对象，并将其存储在那个变量中供你使用。所以你可以创建，是的，你可以用这种方式创建按钮、文本字段、标签和各种不同的 UI 元素。你也可以调用任何你需要调用的编程 API。明白了。所以如果你正在使用 NativeScript，有没有类似 HTML 的东西？换句话说，如果你正在构建一个网站，你有 HTML，比如静态 HTML，它只是描述了，你知道，所有东西的占位符。
which would select a div that has a specific ID. Well, in NativeScript, you can say var color equals uicolor.init with whatever the method is in iOS. And it'll actually give you a native iOS color object and store that for you in that variable. So you can create, yeah, you can create buttons this way and text fields and labels and all sorts of different UI elements. And you can also call any programmatic API that you need to. Gotcha. So if you're using native script, is there sort of an equivalent of HTML? Like, in other words, if you're building a website, you have HTML, like static HTML, that just kind of describes, you know, the placeholders for everything.
然后你有 JavaScript 来注入所有内容。这样你的代码就不会有，你知道，color equals green 之类的东西在代码里。NativeScript 有没有等价物，你知道，皮肤、样式与代码是分离的？是的，是的。而且它使用的是 XML，每次我说这个时我都会有点畏缩，因为我想每个人都觉得有点，你知道，XML 就像暴力，如果它不起作用，说明你用得不够多，我想这是关于 XML 的老话，就像从来没有人用过 XML 然后说，哦，那太棒了，让我们再做一次。是的，但那真的是因为在过去，你知道，我们使用 XML 来传输数据，这并不是 XML 设计的目的。
And then you have JavaScript that kind of injects all the content. And that way it's like your code doesn't have, you know, color equals green and stuff like that in the code. Is there some equivalent for NativeScript where, you know, the skin, the style is kind of separated from the code? Yes, yes. And it's XML is what's used and i always cringe a little bit when i say that because i think everybody's like a little bit you know xml is like violence if it's not working you're not using enough of it i think is the the old saying about xml like nobody ever used xml and was like oh that was awesome let's do it again yeah but it's really because in the past, you know, we used XML to transmit data, which is not really what XML was designed to do.
如果你回去读 Tim，那个人是谁？他曾在 Apple 工作，是 XML 联盟的成员。总之，他的观点是它不是为了，它是为了文档设计的。它不是为了。Tim Bray。是的，Bray，他。所以总之，他的观点是它不是为了到处发送数据。但那正是我们用 SOAP 协议之类的东西所做的。
If you go back and read Tim, what's the guy? He used to work at Apple, was on the XML consortium. Anyway, his point was it wasn't meant for, it was meant for documents. It was not meant for. Tim Bray. Yes, Bray, him. And so anyway, his point is it wasn't meant to send data around yet. That's what we did with soap protocols and whatnot.
但它实际上非常，非常适合组合用户界面，因为就像 HTML 一样，它是一种标记语言。事实上，它们非常，非常，非常相似。所以 NativeScript 使用 XML 标签来标记页面。所以对于一个 NativeScript 页面，你会有一个 page 元素，对吧？所以 page XML 标签。然后在它内部，就像树一样，DOM 树，你会有一种布局，比如 stack layout 或 grid layout。然后在它内部，你会有一个按钮或文本字段或任何你有的东西。
But it's actually very, very good for composing user interfaces because just like HTML, it's a markup language. In fact, they're very, very, very similar. And so NativeScript uses XML tags to mark up a page. So for a NativeScript page, you would have a page element, right? So page XML tags. And then inside of that, just like with a tree, with a DOM tree, you would have some sort of layout, like a stack layout or a grid layout. And then inside of that, you would have a button or a text field or whatever you had.
你会用这些 XML 元素组合你的页面。然后在运行时，NativeScript 解析那个 XML 文件并为你创建原生的等价组件，这样你的屏幕就被布局好了，你不需要通过代码做所有这些事情。明白了。有道理。那 CSS 呢？有没有类似的东西？是的，有。NativeScript 非常努力地保持接近 Web 原则。所以当你去设置组件样式时，NativeScript 实现了 CSS 属性的一个子集。所以它不能实现所有的 CSS 属性，因为它们太多了，而且并非所有属性都适用。但我认为它实现了大约 90% 最常用的属性。所以像 padding、margin、border、opacity、gradient 之类的东西。
And you would compose your page with these XML elements. And then at runtime, NativeScript parses that XML file and creates the native equivalent components for you so that your screen is laid out and you're not doing all of that via code. Gotcha. That makes sense. What about CSS? Is there like an equivalent to that? Yes, there is. NativeScript tries really hard to stay close to web tenants. And so when you go to style components, NativeScript implements a subset of CSS properties. So it can't implement all the CSS properties because there's a ton of them and not all of them are applicable. But I think it implements like 90% of the most used properties. So things like padding, margin, border, opacity, gradient, things like that.
这就是你设置组件样式的方法。所以你实际上使用 CSS 和样式表。所以如果你有一个名为 main.xml 的页面，并且你有一个名为 main.css 的文件，这两个文件会自动被 NativeScript 匹配起来，然后你可以使用类、ID 和常规 CSS 选择器来选择元素，然后像对待 HTML 那样用类来设置它们的样式。明白了，有道理。那么如果有什么，呃，比较具体的东西会发生什么？我试着举个例子，比如 iOS 上的 Force Touch。我的意思是，在这种情况下，你知道，如果必须有某种函数，我想如果你在 Android 上它什么都不做，你知道，我的意思是，基本上
And that's how you style the components. So you actually use CSS and style sheets. So if you had a page called main.xml and you had a file called main.css those two files are automatically matched up by native script and then you can use classes and ids and regular css selectors to select elements and then style them with classes the way that you would html gotcha that makes sense so what happens if there's something uh kind of specific i'm trying to make an example like force touch on ios um i mean in that case you know if if there has to be some kind of function that i guess does nothing if you're on android you know i mean like there's there's basically
平台之间存在不兼容性，NativeScript 是如何协调这一点的呢？对，NativeScript 有它的，它有一个基础抽象层，它抽象了许多通用的触摸操作。所以像点击、双击、长按、双指点击，这些你在几乎所有触摸设备上都能找到的东西。
incompatibilities between the platform how does native script sort of reconcile that right so native script has its, it has a base abstraction layer to which it abstracts a lot of the touches that are universal. So things like tap, double tap, long press, two finger tap, things that you'll find pretty much across all touch devices.
而且有一长串这样的东西。所以这些它是开箱即用的，并且它在各个平台上标准化了这些操作。但确实存在某些交互，例如，有 Force Touch。嗯，Force Touch 存在于 iOS 中，但不存在于 Android 中。所以对于那个场景，你会使用 Force Touch 插件。所以我们所有的插件都是通过 NPM，NPM 注册表交付的，因为它们是 JavaScript。所以如果你只是去 NPM 注册表并搜索 NativeScript，你会看到有 300 多个插件，所以社区中的人们，他们所做的是他们采用这些原生库，
And there's a laundry list of those. So those it provides out of the box and it normalizes those across platforms. But there are certain interactions like, for instance, there is force touch. Well, force touch exists in iOS, but does not exist in Android. So for that scenario, you would use the force touch plugin. So all of our plugins are delivered via NPM, the NPM registry, because they are JavaScript. And so if you just go to the npm registry and do natives and search for native script you'll see there's like 300 and something plugins and so the community folks in the community what they do is they take these native libraries and
然后用 JavaScript 包装它们，然后交付给人们，这样使用它们的人只需要使用 JavaScript，他们甚至不需要调用原生 API，他们可以调用 JavaScript 抽象。所以对于 Force Touch，有一个 ForceTouch 插件。还有一个用于 Touch ID 的插件，这是另一个可能可用也可能不可用的功能，取决于你使用的设备。然后 NativeScript
then they wrap them with javascript and then deliver them to people so that the people consuming them can just use the javascript they don't even have to call the native apis they can call the javascript abstraction so for force touch there is a plugin for ForceTouch. There's also one for Touch ID, which is another one that may or may not be available depending on the device you're on. Then NativeScript
非常了解平台。这意味着我们理解当人们构建应用时，在不同的操作系统之间会出现各种各样这样的问题，他们必须针对特定类型的设备定位特定功能。所以就像 Force Touch 是个例子。所以任何时候在 NativeScript 中，当你想要做一些 iOS 特定的事情时，你可以说 if iOS，因为 iOS 是一个全局变量，对吧？NativeScript 只是，是的，它总是知道。
is very platform aware. What that means is that we understand that when people are building applications, there's going to be all sorts of issues like this between the different operating systems where they're going to have to target a specific feature for a specific kind of device. So it's like force touch is the example. So anytime in native script, when you want to do something that's iOS specific, you can say if iOS, because iOS is a global variable, right? And NativeScript just, yes, it's always aware.
然后它还允许你用其他几种不同的方式来做。如果你有一个，比如你有一个主页面，你有两个不同的主页面，一个用于 iOS，一个用于 Android。如果你把那个主页面称为 main.ios.xml 和 main.android.xml，它们将只会被加载在那些，
And then it also allows you to do that in a couple of other different ways. If you have like a, say you have a main page and you have two different main pages, one for iOS and one for Android. If you call that main page main.ios.xml and main.android.xml, they will only be loaded on those,
适用的平台上。标记也是一样。标记也是一样。如果在标记中你给属性加上 iOS 或 Android 前缀，该属性只在两个平台中的一个上生效。明白了，有道理。是的，所以在任何现实生活场景中，你只能走这么远
on the applicable platform. Same with the markup. Same with the markup. If in the markup you prefix an attribute with iOS or Android, that attribute only takes effect on one of those two platforms. Gotcha, that makes sense. Yeah, so in any real life scenario, you're only gonna get so far
在你真正想要利用设备特定功能之前。天哪，不知道为什么这很难说出来。是的，这是一个很好的答案。是的，NativeScript 知道这一点，所以我们尽量让你尽可能容易地说，好吧，现在，在这种情况下，做这件事，如果它不存在，那么就不要执行这块代码
before you really wanna take advantage of device specific features. Man, that was hard to get out for some reason. Yeah, that's a good answer. Yeah, and Nittyscript knows that, and so we try to make it as easy as possible for you to say, okay, now, in this case, do this thing, and if it's not there, then just don't execute this block of code
或者不要显示这部分 UI。明白了，所以想法是如果你在做基本的事情，比如如果你在做一个计算餐厅小费的应用之类的，那么你几乎肯定只会停留在支持所有主要平台的 API 范围内。但如果你必须做一些像应用内购买或非常具体的事情，那么就有相应的插件。是的，绝对是。而且我认为，你知道，表单优于数据，这在移动开发或一般开发中，我们所做的很多事情都是一遍又一遍地解决同样的问题。
or don't show this piece of UI. Gotcha, so the idea is if you're doing the basic thing, like if you're making an app to calculate the tip at a restaurant or something, then you'll almost certainly just stay within the APIs that support all the major platforms. But then if you have to do something like in-app purchases or something really specific, then there are plugins for that. Yeah, absolutely. And I think that, you know, forms over data, which is really in mobile development or in development in general, a lot of what we're doing is solving the same problems over and over and over again.
特别是如果你做企业开发或者你主要处理大数据集，你主要是在获取数据、显示它、编辑它，然后以不同的方式可视化它。所以当涉及到表单优于数据时，比如文本框、按钮、标签以及显示数据并将其发回服务器，所有这些东西都在 NativeScript 框架中。
Especially if you do enterprise dev or you're primarily working with large data sets, you're primarily taking data, displaying it, editing it, and then visualizing it in different ways. And so when it comes're primarily taking data, displaying it, editing it, and then visualizing it in different ways. And so when it comes to forms over data, which would be like text boxes and buttons and labels and displaying data and sending it back to the server, all of those things are in the NativeScript framework.
但移动端真正酷的地方在于你可以用移动端做很多很棒的事情。我的意思是，你可以使用很多不同的功能。你知道，有加速度计，有，你知道，有 Force Touch，有屏幕旋转，有各种各样很酷的东西。作为移动应用的开发者，你希望能够使用所有这些东西，因为那才是让它如此神奇的原因。那才是让应用引人入胜的原因。不是文本框、标签和按钮。而是移动平台能做的所有很酷的事情。所以一旦你想扩展到那个领域，那就是你开始为你想针对的每一件事使用那些插件的时候。
But what's really cool about mobile is there's so many awesome things that you can do with mobile. I mean, there's so many different features that you can use. You know, there's accelerometers and there's, you know, there's force touch, there's screen rotation, there's all sorts of cool things. And as a developer of mobile apps, you want to be able to use all that stuff because that's what makes it so amazing. That's what makes apps engaging. It's not text boxes and labels and buttons. It's all the cool things the mobile platforms can do. And so once you want to expand into that area, that's when you begin to use those plugins for each one of those things that you want to target.
或者你直接从 JavaScript 调用原生 API，取决于你对哪一个更熟悉。明白了。有道理。所以，你知道，曾经有一段时间，JavaScript 原生工具出现了一种寒武纪大爆发，对吧？所以有 Appcelerator。有，我想，来自 Intel 的东西，或者也许 Intel 收购了 Appcelerator。有 NativeScript。有 React Native。可能还有一堆我一时想不起来的其他东西。但某种程度上，我想，你知道，过去几年我没有关注它。所以所有这些不同的替代方案发生了什么
Or you just call the native APIs directly from JavaScript, depending on which one you're more comfortable with. Gotcha. That makes sense. So, you know, there was at one point there was this sort of Cambrian explosion of JavaScript native utilities, right? So there was AppCelerator. There was, I think, something from Intel, or maybe Intel bought AppCelerator. There's NativeScript. There's React Native. There's probably a bunch of others that I can't think of off the top of my head. But sort of, I guess, you know, I haven't been following it in the past few years. So what happened to all these different alternatives
它们各自的优缺点是什么？嗯，我知道对于 Appcelerator，我不太了解 Appcelerator，但 Appcelerator 是第一个尝试这种方法和策略的公司。所以真的，NativeScript 和 React Native 在某种程度上是站在 Appcelerator 的肩膀上的，对吧？功劳归功于功劳。
and what are the pros and cons of each of them? Well, I know that for AppCelerator, and I don't know as much about AppCelerator, but AppCelerator was the first one to try this sort of approach and strategy. So really, NativeScript and React Native are standing on the shoulders of Accelerator to a degree, right? Credit where credit was due.
他们是那个领域的先驱。然而，很多时候作为第一个，你会发现所有如果你能重来一次可能不一定会做的事情。然后所有跟在你后面的人都可以说，好吧，嗯，我们只是不会那样做，因为那显然行不通。所以，你知道，Appcelerator 仍然很强劲。有很多很棒的、出色的 Appcelerator 开发者
They were pioneers in that space. However, a lot of times being first, you get to find out all of the stuff that you might not necessarily do if you could do it over. And then all the people that come behind you get to go, okay, well, we're just not going to do that because that obviously doesn't work. And so, you know, an accelerator is still going strong. There's a lot of great, fantastic accelerator devs out there
和很棒的应用。所以我不太了解它，但它与 NativeScript 相似，因为里面有 JavaScript 虚拟机。React Native 可能更接近 NativeScript，因为这是我们所说的 JavaScript 的新一代。我们称之为 JavaScript Native。那里没有一个很好的术语，但我们通常这样称呼它。但它也使用 JavaScript 虚拟机。React Native 和 NativeScript 在基本层面上的区别在于
and great apps. So I don't know as much about it, but it is similar to NativeScript in so much as there's a JavaScript virtual machine in there somewhere. React Native is probably closer to NativeScript because this is sort of the new generation of what we'll call JavaScript. We call it JavaScript Native. There's not a real good piece of terminology there, but that's generally what we refer to it as. But it also uses a JavaScript virtual machine. The difference between React Native and NativeScript at a fundamental level is that
React Native 不试图包装整个操作系统以便你可以从 JavaScript 访问它。相反，它让你做的是让你在 Xcode 或 Android Studio、Java 或 Objective-C Swift 中构建你的原生代码，然后通过 JavaScript 包装器暴露它，然后将其导入到你的项目中。第二件事是 React Native。等等，你能再重复一遍吗？我觉得我的大脑刚刚融化了。所以你用 Swift 写了一些东西，然后它用 React Native 变成了 JavaScript？
React Native does not try to wrap the entire operating system so that you can access it from JavaScript. Instead, what it has you do is it has you build your right native code in Xcode or Android Studio, Java, or Objective-C Swift, and then expose that via a JavaScript wrapper, then import that into your project. The second thing is React Native. Wait, can you repeat that one more time? I think my brain just melted. So you write something in Swift, and then it goes to JavaScript with React Native?
是的。而且我相信有人会写信告诉我这实际上是，对吧？这不完全正确，但据我所知，如果你有一个你想要访问的特定原生功能，好吧，所以假设有一些 API。假设你正在使用
Yes. And I'm sure someone's going to write in and tell me about how this is well, actually, right? This is not exactly correct, but as I understand it, if you have a specific native feature that you want to access, all right, so let's say there's some API. Let's say you're working with
iOS 上的 HomeKit。你构建了一些插件来控制你的灯光或让你的车库门上下移动等等。所以你用 Objective-C 或 Swift 编写那个原生代码。然后 React Native 使用 JavaScript 和原生代码之间的桥梁，类似于我们所做的方式。但然后你必须把这两样东西拿过来并导入到你的项目中。所以你采用原生代码，你采用将要调用那个原生代码的 JavaScript 包装器，你把它们带进来，然后你就可以访问那个 API 了。
HomeKit on iOS. And you built some plugin to control your lights or make your garage or go up and down or whatever. So you write that native code in Objective-C or Swift. And then there is a bridge between JavaScript and native code that React Native uses similar to how we do it. But then you have to take those two things and import them into your project. So you take the native code and you take the JavaScript wrapper that's gonna call into that native code and you bring those in and then you can access that API.
那么这有什么不同呢？与 NativeScript 的区别——哦，是的，请继续。所以，嗯，在 NativeScript 中，你不必出去编写那个原生代码。你可以直接从 JavaScript 调用它。我知道这有点令人困惑。所以有某种翻译。
So how is that different? The difference with native- Oh yeah, go ahead. So, well, in native script, you don't have to go out and write that native code. You can just call it from JavaScript. Which I know is kind of confusing. So there's some kind of translation.
就像如果你说函数 X，没关系。就像如果他们制作了一个新函数，已经有某种方法可以在 JavaScript 中表示它了。是的，是的。所以就像我说的，早些时候我们谈到了使用像 UI Color，但如果你做了，比如你正在使用一个按钮，你会说 UI Button init with cgrect 或者它是什么，cgrect 0，你的 JavaScript 实际上看起来就是那样。
Like if you say function X, it doesn't matter. Like if they make a new function, there's some way to represent that in JavaScript already. Yes, yes. So like I said, earlier we talked about using like a UI color, but if you did, like let's say you were using a button, you would say UI button init with cgrect or whatever it is, cgrect 0, and your JavaScript would actually look like that.
然后 NativeScript 会编组底层的按钮对象并将其返回给你。所以你确实是在编写 Objective-C API，但你是在用 JavaScript 形式编写它。所以没有括号语法。它只是 JavaScript。明白了。好的，有道理。
And then Natascript would marshal the underlying button object and give that back to you. So you really are writing Objective-C APIs, but you're writing it in a JavaScript form. So there's no bracket syntax. It's just JavaScript. Got it. Okay, that makes sense.
所以我猜，所以我明白了。所以你有一个抽象 iOS 和 Android 的层，但那一层本身也是用 JavaScript 编写的。在底层，它为我使用了你的底层魔法，因为我只知道技术上到目前为止，但在某个点它变成了像 C++ 和汇编代码来完成那个转换，对吧？而且为了速度，因为如果你从 JavaScript 跳到 Objective-C 再到字节码，你每次在它们之间移动时都会受到性能影响。明白了。
And so I guess, so I see. So you have some layer that abstracts iOS and Android, but that layer itself is also written in JavaScript. And under the hood, it uses your lower level magic for me because I only know technically so far, but at some point it turns into like C++ and assembly code to make that transition, right? And in order to be fast too, because if you jump from JavaScript to Objective-C to bytecode, you take a performance hit each time you move between those. Gotcha.
所以为了速度，我们尽量在可能的时候直接去汇编。对。所以幕后有很多这样的事情。那是运行时的一部分。明白了。所以基本上，如果你在家，你想用 JavaScript 制作一个 iPhone 和 Android 应用，不要自己做。这真的很难。
And so in order to be fast, we try to go directly to assembly when possible. Right. So there's a lot of that that goes on behind the scenes. That's part of the runtime. Gotcha. So basically, if you're at home and you want to use JavaScript to make an iPhone and an Android app, don't do it yourself. It's really hard.
使用 NativeScript 或 React Native 或这些工具之一。对，是的。是这些智能运行时之一，如果你愿意的话。是的。这就是想法，对吧？是我们把所有的工作都投入到运行时中，然后运行时基本上抽象出来
Use native script or React Native or one of these tools. Right, yes. It's one of these smart runtimes, if you will. Yes. And that's the idea, right? Is that we put all the work into the runtime and then the runtime basically abstracts out
并使这成为一种非常优雅、非常标准化、非常理智的方式来编写跨平台原生移动应用。明白了。所以有点扮演魔鬼代言人，我的意思是，有 Apache Cordova，我想它过去被称为 PhoneGap。还有其他一些这样的工具，你可以把一个网站有效地包装成一个应用，当，当你，你知道，它看起来像一个应用，就像你在主屏幕上有应用的图标。然后当你打开它时，它实际上只是打开了一个浏览器，但没有地址栏。所以，你知道，你真的看不出它是一个
and makes this very graceful, very normalized, very sane way to write cross-platform native mobile applications. Gotcha. So kind of playing Dell's advocate here, I mean, there's Apache Cordova, which I think used to be called PhoneGap. And there's some other tools like this, where you can take a website and effectively wrap it into an app where the, when you, you know, it looks like an app, like you have the icon of an app on your home screen. And then when you open it, it's really just opening a browser, but without the address bar. So, you know, you can't really tell it's a
浏览器，但它，它实际上只是一个 Web，你知道，你在手机上的网站。所以为什么，为什么那不是圣杯？你知道？看起来你可以直接拿你的网站，使用 PhoneGap，把它包装成这个应用，然后你就完成了。嗯，如果它那样工作确实会很好。不幸的是，实际上我们最终得到 NativeScript 的方式是，我在这里必须小心，因为混合开发是一项非常重要的技术，而且它仍然非常相关。然而，用例，我认为，不是它曾经的样子。所以 Progress 制造开发者工具。这就是我们所做的。所以我们所做的一部分是我们制造移动开发者工具。曾经有一段时间，我们所有的工具都是基于 Cordova 构建的。我们发现 Cordova 可以构建应用，你 80% 的时间会
browser, but it's, it's actually just a web, you know, your website on the phone. And so just why, why isn't that the Holy grail? You know? It seems like you could just take your website, use PhoneGap, and wrap it into this app, and then you're just done. Well, it would sure be nice if it worked that way. Unfortunately, and actually the way we ended up at NativeScript is, and I have to be careful here, because hybrid is a very important piece of technology and it's still very relevant. However, the use case, I think, is not what it once was. So progress makes developer tools. That's what we do. And so part of what we do is we make mobile developer tools. And at one point in time, we had built all of our tooling on Cordova. And what we discovered was that Cordova could build applications and 80% of your time would be
花在构建应用上，它会花你大约一个小时，对吧？而且它会很棒，因为你所有的 Web 技能都会起作用，然后你接下来的 80% 的时间会花在试图让这个东西表现正常上，试图让按钮点击事件起作用，试图让滚动起作用。滚动会非常卡顿，特别是如果你使用图像，它会崩溃，它会锁死，离线很奇怪。这是因为你在这些不同的设备、这些不同的操作系统上有所有这些不同的浏览器。而且它们都与设备本身沙盒化了。因为设备制造商不想仅仅允许对 Web 上的任何东西进行完全的设备访问
spent building the application and it would take you like an hour right and it would be amazing because all your web skills would just work and then the next 80% of your time would be spent trying to make this thing just behave right trying to make button click events work, trying to make scrolling work. Scrolling would be incredibly janky, especially if you were using images, it would flake out, it would lock up, offline was weird. And this is because you have all these different browsers on these different devices on these different operating systems. And all of them are sandboxed from the device itself. because device makers don't want to just allow full device access to anything on the web
因为这意味着你可以加载一个网页，它可能会占用你所有的 CPU 和所有的 GPU，并在五分钟内耗尽手机的电池。人们不会责怪网站，他们会责怪设备，对吧？他们会说，我的电池太烂了。
because that means you could load a webpage which could just grab all of your CPU and all of your GPU and drain the battery on the phone in like five minutes flat. And people aren't going to blame the website, they're going to blame the device, right? They're going to be like, my battery sucks.
所以他们为这些移动浏览器所做的是使它们受到非常严格的限制。所以它们没有对 GPU 的完全访问权限。它们不是一等公民。这真的是为了保护操作系统和保护性能。坏处是 Web 在移动端受损。它就是这样。我们已经一次又一次地看到这一点，对吧？比如在他们的网站上放太多广告的人，或者网站上有太多数据，你在移动设备上访问它，你会说，天哪，这太糟糕了。我只想下载应用并让它直接工作。是的，这完全是真的。
And so what they do for these mobile browsers is they make them very restricted. And so they don't have full access to the GPU. They're not a first class citizen. And that's really to protect the operating system and protect performance. The bad thing is that the web suffers on mobile. It just does. And we've seen this over and over and over again, right? Like people that put too many ads in their site, or there's too much data on a site and you visit it on a mobile device and you're like, God, this is so bad. I just want to download the app and have it just work. Yeah, it's totally true.
我的意思是，即使是那些非常努力想做对的人。我在 iPhone 上用 Reddit，我用的是 Web 版本。我通过 Chrome 应用访问，它就是很糟糕。你可以看出 Reddit 在上面投入了这么多精力，因为它比我见过的任何其他移动网站都要好得多。但它就是运行得不好。比如加载，那个小加载 GIF 被复制了。
I mean, even the people who try so hard to get it right. I was on Reddit on my iPhone and I was on the web version. I went through the Chrome app and it was just bad. And you can tell that Reddit put so much effort into it because it was just so much better than any other mobile site I've ever seen. But it just didn't work well. Like the loading, the little loading GIF was duplicated.
有像两个旋转的盒子，还有像那样奇怪的东西。而且我是在 iPhone 上。我甚至不是在一个特别深奥的设备上。是的，那非常真实。而且你知道，有在 Reddit 团队工作的人。他们非常聪明。这些是一些最聪明的开发者。
There was like two spinning boxes and just like weird stuff like that. And I was on an iPhone. I wasn't even on a particularly esoteric device. Yeah, that's very true. And you know, there's folks that work on the Reddit team. They're so bright. These are some of the smartest developers out there.
所以如果你在外面，你构建了一个移动 Web 应用或混合 Web 应用，而它很慢或者它没有像你认为的那样运行，那不是你的错。让我先说出来。而且我认为 Web 开发者认为我们应该像这些性能专家一样，对吧？现在，我们不仅需要了解 Web 平台，我们还需要成为像瀑布图和开发者工具中所有这些东西的专家。而且我看了会议又会议，我仍然不明白发生了什么
And so if you're out there and you've built a mobile web app or a hybrid web app and it is slow or it doesn't function like you think it should, it's not your fault. Let me just be the first to say that. And I think that web developers think that we should be like these performance experts, right? Now, not only do we need to know the web platform, but we also need to be experts on like waterfall charts and all this stuff in the developer tools. And I've watched session after session after session, and I still don't understand what's going on
所以，如果你在外面构建了一个移动端网页应用或混合网页应用，而它运行缓慢或者功能不如你预期的那样，那不是你的错。让我先说这一点。我认为网页开发者觉得我们应该成为性能专家，对吧？现在，我们不仅需要了解网页平台，还需要成为瀑布图和开发者工具中所有这些内容的专家。我看了无数场会议，但我仍然不明白到底发生了什么。
in these perf tools as much as I've tried to do these audits and things myself. And so developers typically blame themselves because we know everything is possible. And so when we build something and it doesn't work right, we take it and we internalize that. But the truth of the matter is that, you know, your feet were tied from the get-go
在这些性能工具中，尽管我尝试过自己进行审计和处理。开发者通常会责怪自己，因为我们知道一切皆有可能。所以当我们构建的东西无法正常工作时，我们会将其内化。但事实是，你的手脚从一开始就被束缚住了。
because you tried to build a native app inside of a web view. And ultimately, it's not going to work out for a myriad of reasons. Yeah, that makes sense. There's also this weird uncanny valley where, you know, you hit a button and it doesn't really slide. I mean, it looks like an iOS app, but the button doesn't slide. It just teleports to the on or off position. And when every single UI element is just a little bit off, it kind of puts you in this really weird state. It's almost worse than if it looked completely different.
因为你试图在网页视图（Web View）中构建原生应用。归根结底，由于种种原因，这是行不通的。是的，这很有道理。还有一种奇怪的“恐怖谷”效应，比如你按下一个按钮，它并没有真正滑动。我的意思是，它看起来像个 iOS 应用，但按钮不会滑动。它只是瞬间传送到开启或关闭的位置。当每一个 UI 元素都有一点偏差时，会让你处于一种非常奇怪的状态。这甚至比看起来完全不同还要糟糕。
Yeah, and, you know, hybrid apps are an imitation of native apps, right? So by definition, they are an imitation. And a lot of times, the second you can tell something is an imitation, you're like, cool, whoa, wait. Those are not real obelisks, right? Uncool. And so it's the same effect there. But we should point out that, look,
是的，你知道，混合应用是对原生应用的模仿，对吧？所以根据定义，它们就是一种模仿。很多时候，当你一眼看出某样东西是模仿品时，你会觉得：酷，等等。那些不是真正的方尖碑，对吧？太逊了。所以这里也是同样的效果。但我们应该指出，看，
hybrid apps still have a really valid use case. Brochure apps, apps that have, that are very simple, that have just a couple of screens. You're not doing a lot of moving around, not a lot of animation, not a lot of data. Perfect for those types of applications. And they're great for prototyping because you can build them so fast, right?
混合应用仍然有非常有效的用例。宣传册类应用，非常简单、只有几个页面的应用。你不需要进行大量的移动、大量的动画或处理大量数据。这些类型的应用非常适合。而且它们非常适合原型设计，因为你可以构建得非常快，对吧？
Hybrid is still the fastest way to build an application. Unfortunately, it's not one that you can ship ultimately, but when you're building out a POC, hybrid apps are great for prototypes. That makes sense. So Unity is really popular. They have a ton of the market share on games and things like that. And Unity lets you deploy to different platforms and they have kind of a UI. And so again, Dell is advocating, why wouldn't I use Unity and, you know, deploy my app that way?
混合开发仍然是构建应用最快的方式。不幸的是，它最终无法发布，但在构建概念验证（POC）时，混合应用非常适合做原型。这很有道理。所以 Unity 非常流行。他们在游戏等领域占据了巨大的市场份额。Unity 允许你部署到不同的平台，而且他们有自己的 UI。所以再次回到开发者倡导的问题，为什么我不使用 Unity 并以那种方式部署我的应用呢？
Well, Unity is targeted at games, though, right? It's a gaming. Yeah, I think it can deploy, but you're right. You're drawing. You don't really have any UI there. Like, you're drawing it all yourself. Like, you're drawing pixel by you don't really have any ui there like you're drawing it all yourself like you're drawing pixel by pixel or picture by picture yeah unity isn't trying to make a look like a native app right all the unity games i played the buttons are all like game buttons
嗯，Unity 是针对游戏的，对吧？它是游戏引擎。是的，我想它可以部署，但你是对的。你在绘图。你那里并没有真正的 UI。就像是你自己画出来的一样。就像你逐像素或逐图地绘制。是的，Unity 并没有试图让它看起来像原生应用，对吧？我玩过的所有 Unity 游戏，按钮看起来都像游戏按钮。
right oh yeah that's true yeah so it's it's it's a different purpose it's really hard to make a ui and then when you do it's you do, it's way too low level. It would take you forever. I don't know that it's hard to make a UI. They're just not trying to make it look native. I don't believe they're using native components. It's like a drawing framework. I guess it's OpenGL.
对，哦，是的，那是真的。所以这是不同的目的。制作 UI 非常困难，而且当你做出来时，它的层级太低了。这会花费你很长时间。我不知道制作 UI 是否困难。他们只是没有试图让它看起来像原生的。我不认为他们在使用原生组件。它就像一个绘图框架。我想是 OpenGL。
Everything is being drawn to the screen. Yeah, you're drawing a HUD, a heads-up display. For some reason, I thought that the UI part of... So that's really hard then, never mind. Because, I mean, so then if you want, you know, I mean, getting a little bit off topic here, but if you wanted, you know, a button in Unity, you literally have to draw an up position button
所有东西都被绘制到屏幕上。是的，你在绘制一个 HUD（平视显示器）。出于某种原因，我以为 UI 部分……所以那确实很难，没关系。因为，我的意思是，如果你想要，你知道，这里有点跑题了，但如果你在 Unity 中想要一个按钮，你必须逐个绘制按下状态的按钮
and a down position. Like, there's no way to get a button from the OS itself You know, I mean like it's just a different use case for mobile apps, right? You probably wouldn't write Pokemon go with native script. Oh, you could unity would be a better choice there But you probably wouldn't use unity to write an application which keeps track of inventory and shows you charts and graphs Which you can then export to email. Gotcha, because there's so much of the UI you'd have to write yourself, it wouldn't look good.
和松开状态。就像，没有办法从操作系统本身获取按钮。你知道，我的意思是这只是移动应用的不同用例，对吧？你可能不会用 NativeScript 写《精灵宝可梦 GO》。哦，你可以，但 Unity 在那里会是更好的选择。但你可能不会使用 Unity 来编写一个跟踪库存、显示图表并可以导出到电子邮件的应用程序。明白了，因为有太多的 UI 需要你自己写，而且看起来不会很好。
And you'd be better off writing to apps or using NativeScript or React Native. Yeah, correct, something that you were more familiar with. And obviously the idea with NativeScript and React Native being that you can use JavaScript to do that, and that's the language a lot of people know. They already know how to make an AJAX call with JavaScript. Well, you can make that same AJAX call in NativeScript. They already know how to use local storage. Well, you can also use that in
你最好还是写两个应用，或者使用 NativeScript 或 React Native。是的，没错，使用你更熟悉的工具。显然，NativeScript 和 React Native 的理念是你可以使用 JavaScript 来完成这些工作，这是很多人都懂的语言。他们已经知道如何用 JavaScript 进行 AJAX 调用。好吧，你可以在 NativeScript 中进行同样的 AJAX 调用。他们已经知道如何使用本地存储。好吧，你也可以在
NativeScript except in NativeScript it uses core data. So all these concepts that people have for the web translate directly to mobile, but end up giving them the app that they wanted, not the app that they were stuck with. So maybe to ask your question, Jason, in a slightly, well, not the same question, but a slightly different question, a similar vein is, you know, we've talked about why NativeScript or, to be fair, React Native work well, but when is the time not to use them? So you kind of pointed out hybrid app is good for relatively simple apps what about like on the complex end what is a sign that your app is maybe too complex or too performant or something and you should consider writing breaking down and writing actual native code i don't know that it's as much an issue of size and performance because you do have native these
NativeScript 中使用它，只不过在 NativeScript 中它使用的是 Core Data。所以人们在 Web 上拥有的所有概念都可以直接转化为移动端，最终给他们想要的应用，而不是被困在某种应用中。所以，为了以稍微不同的方式问你的问题，Jason，虽然不是同一个问题，但思路相似，我们讨论了为什么 NativeScript 或 React Native 运行良好，但什么时候不应该使用它们呢？你指出了混合应用适合相对简单的应用，那么在复杂的一端，有什么迹象表明你的应用可能太复杂或性能要求太高，你应该考虑拆解并编写真正的原生代码？我不认为这更多是规模和性能的问题，因为你确实拥有原生这些
are native apps that you're getting with react native and native script right so closing the gap there I think it's more a question of skill set so does your company have a mobile a mobility division with stacked with iOS and Android developers if so you should probably just build native mobile apps because you already have the skills in-house. They're already there. If your company, like a lot, doesn't have the luxury of having that sort of skill set and you have a couple of developers who are tasked with doing everything, right? They do the web. They do desktop. They do mobile.
通过 React Native 和 NativeScript 获得的是原生应用，对吧？所以缩小了差距。我认为这更多是技能组合的问题。你们公司是否有配备 iOS 和 Android 开发人员的移动部门？如果是这样，你可能应该直接构建原生移动应用，因为你们内部已经具备了这些技能。他们已经在那里了。如果你们公司像许多公司一样，没有那种技能组合的奢侈，而你们只有几个开发人员负责所有事情，对吧？他们做 Web，做桌面，做移动端。
They do database administration. They write queries. They build reports. They do everything, which is that's by and large most people out there, then you're going to want something you can't afford to build those native mobile applications. So that's when you would go back to native script. So it's really just an issue of skill set and the tools that you need and what's available, I think. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, I think the... Oh, did we
他们做数据库管理。他们写查询。他们构建报告。他们做所有事情，这在很大程度上是大多数人的情况，那么你就会想要一些你负担得起的东西，你负担不起构建那些原生移动应用。所以这就是你会回到 NativeScript 的时候。所以我认为这真的只是技能组合、你需要的工具以及现有资源的问题。是的，这很有道理。是的，我想……哦，我们
lose Patrick? Are you there, Patrick? Nope, I'm here. Oh, okay. I heard a weird buzzing. Anyways, so, I mean, this is a really hard question to answer, I guess, but, I mean, I think around maybe... There was a time where a lot of companies were doing the web thing. I think around maybe there was a time where a lot of companies were doing the web thing.
失去 Patrick 了吗？你在吗，Patrick？不，我在。哦，好的。我听到一阵奇怪的嗡嗡声。总之，我的意思是，这是一个很难回答的问题，我想，但是，我的意思是，我认为大约……曾经有一段时间，很多公司都在做 Web 那一套。我想大约……曾经有一段时间，很多公司都在做 Web 那一套。
I think like Facebook was one of them. The Facebook app was all HTML. There's some other companies where that was the thing. And then kind of people moved away from that to writing native apps. And then I feel like NativeScript and react native is kind of the third sort of generation of that where a lot of companies as you said companies who don't necessarily have the expertise or want to kind of move quickly and develop on both platforms we'll use that what do you think is is next in other words like what's what if if you could
我想 Facebook 就是其中之一。Facebook 应用全是 HTML。还有其他一些公司也是这样。然后人们逐渐转向编写原生应用。我觉得 NativeScript 和 React Native 是第三代，正如你所说，那些不一定具备专业知识或希望快速行动并在两个平台上开发的公司会使用它。你认为接下来会发生什么？换句话说，如果你能
predict the next paradigm shift what would it be be? Oh, that's a great question. Well, I actually think that, well, let me say, let me speak for NativeScript first and then maybe for the industry. For NativeScript itself, right now, NativeScript, one of the big differences between NativeScript and React Native is that React Native has you write React. And NativeScript is a JavaScript runtime. So it supports JavaScript, but it also supports Angular too. So really, you're addressing two different camps here, those who want to write React and those who want to write Angular. For NativeScript itself, as it goes forward,
预测下一次范式转移，那会是什么？哦，这是一个很好的问题。嗯，我实际上认为，嗯，让我先代表 NativeScript 说，然后再代表整个行业说。对于 NativeScript 本身，目前，NativeScript 和 React Native 之间的主要区别之一是 React Native 要求你编写 React。而 NativeScript 是一个 JavaScript 运行时。所以它支持 JavaScript，但也支持 Angular 2。所以实际上，你是在针对两个不同的阵营，那些想写 React 的人和那些想写 Angular 的人。对于 NativeScript 本身，随着它的发展，
I think that evolution for NativeScript is that just like the browser, you don't say, hey, I'm using Chrome for Angular. You don't say that. You just say, I'm using Chrome and Angular works inside. But so does React, so does Backbone, so does Knockout, so does Vue, any of the other JavaScript frameworks. NativeScript as a runtime, as it matures, should eventually get to the point where you can drop
我认为 NativeScript 的演变就像浏览器一样，你不会说：“嘿，我正在用 Chrome 运行 Angular。”你不会那样说。你只会说：“我正在使用 Chrome，而 Angular 在里面运行。”但 React 也可以，Backbone 也可以，Knockout 也可以，Vue 也可以，任何其他 JavaScript 框架都可以。NativeScript 作为运行时，随着它的成熟，最终应该达到你可以放入
any JavaScript framework in there, just like you would on the web, and you can use it with NativeScript in a perfect scenario. That makes sense so nature is like like the browser in the same way as like the browser is just a platform upon which you build your website and it doesn't matter you know anything uh so yeah i guess native script would be kind of like a fully featured browser where any library would just work. Correct. And then I think for the industry at large,
任何 JavaScript 框架的地步，就像你在 Web 上所做的那样，并且在理想情况下，你可以将其与 NativeScript 一起使用。这很有道理，所以 NativeScript 就像浏览器一样，就像浏览器只是一个构建网站的平台，它不关心任何东西……所以是的，我想 NativeScript 会像一个功能齐全的浏览器，任何库都能直接运行。没错。然后对于整个行业，
are you guys familiar with Android Instant Apps? No, I haven't heard of it. Have you heard of these? No. Okay, so this is fascinating. Basically what they do is they take Android apps and they split them up into shards and then you actually take just a piece of that app.
你们熟悉 Android Instant Apps 吗？不，我没听说过。你听说过吗？没有。好吧，这太迷人了。基本上他们所做的是，他们获取 Android 应用并将它们拆分成碎片，然后你实际上只获取该应用的一小部分。
So let's say you have, I mean, let's say you're OpenTable, actually downloads and installs that little shard of the native application, but only the piece that allows you to make that reservation. Now, once you've got that little piece on your device, you can then choose to install the rest of the application, or you can casually just say, nope, and it'll be removed the second that you navigate away. So it's kind of this weird blend of like the web, which is how we find everything, because app stores are abysmal for finding things. They're terrible.
所以假设你是 OpenTable，它实际上下载并安装了原生应用的那一小部分，但仅限于允许你进行预订的那一部分。现在，一旦你的设备上有了那一小部分，你就可以选择安装应用程序的其余部分，或者你可以随意说“不”，当你导航离开时，它就会被删除。所以这是一种奇怪的 Web 混合体，这是我们发现一切的方式，因为应用商店在发现事物方面非常糟糕。它们太烂了。
With native apps, which provide performance on otherwise low-end devices. So it's it, I mean, I'm trying to think of this from a UI perspective is it kind of like an iframe where you this little frame inside the web browser pops up with native controls or does actually take you to an app and then back? It actually loads a piece of that native app on your device without you installing anything it like install and I don't know the internals of how it works, but I think that's the future. I haven't seen anything like that for iOS, but this idea that I can use just the piece of the native app that I need and I can do that from the internet and I can find it that way,
结合了在低端设备上提供性能的原生应用。所以，我的意思是，我正试图从 UI 的角度来思考这个问题，它是否有点像 iframe，你在 Web 浏览器中弹出的这个小框架带有原生控件，还是它实际上把你带到一个应用然后又回来？它实际上在你的设备上加载了原生应用的一小部分，而无需你安装任何东西，它就像安装一样，我不知道它内部是如何工作的，但我认为这就是未来。我还没有在 iOS 上看到类似的东西，但这种我可以只使用我需要的原生应用片段，并且我可以从互联网上做到这一点，我可以通过这种方式找到它，
that's how I discover native apps. To me, that's mind-blowing. That's great. That's awesome. Yeah, I wonder, I mean mean what's to stop them from um let me think about this so i mean you could have a website where if the person's on a desktop they get the website and if they're on mobile they get this instant app but then I guess if you could if there's some if you okay if you could run NativeScript on the browser then you would sort of unify all the platforms right so in other words if if if you
这就是我发现原生应用的方式。对我来说，这太令人震惊了。太棒了。太酷了。是的，我想知道，我的意思是，有什么能阻止他们……让我考虑一下，所以我的意思是，你可以拥有一个网站，如果用户在桌面上，他们会得到网站，如果他们在移动设备上，他们会得到这个即时应用，但我想如果你能……如果你可以在浏览器上运行 NativeScript，那么你就会统一所有平台，对吧？所以换句话说，如果你
could write NativeScript and it would create a website for a desktop or laptop and also an app, then you would be done. You wouldn't have to do double work. Right, and that's actually where Angular 2 comes in because Angular 2, which is the next version of the Angular framework, I don't know how close you guys follow JavaScript frameworks, but it's been in development for a long time. It was just released final. But one of the things that it really focuses on
可以编写 NativeScript，它会为桌面或笔记本电脑创建一个网站，同时也会创建一个应用，那么你就完成了。你不必做双倍的工作。没错，这正是 Angular 2 的用武之地，因为 Angular 2 是 Angular 框架的下一个版本，我不知道你们关注 JavaScript 框架有多密切，但它已经开发了很长时间。它刚刚发布了最终版本。但它真正关注的事情之一
is removing the dependency of the renderer from the browser. So when we write our websites, we build them, we're usually very tightly coupled to the browser, right? We're making DOM calls, we're selecting elements from the page, we're updating those elements directly from JavaScript. Well, Angular 2 says, no, no, no, don't do that. Use these normalized APIs and let Angular handle
是消除渲染器对浏览器的依赖。所以当我们编写网站时，我们构建它们，通常与浏览器耦合非常紧密，对吧？我们在进行 DOM 调用，我们从页面中选择元素，我们直接从 JavaScript 更新这些元素。好吧，Angular 2 说，不，不，不，不要那样做。使用这些标准化的 API，让 Angular 处理
all of the updating of the actual UI and vice versa. And that's called the renderer. So what NativeScript does is NativeScript comes in and says, okay, the browser was the renderer before, I'm the renderer now. So you can actually, we've done this, we are working on tooling that allows you to create one application that targets both web and mobile from the same application. Now, the difference is you're building two different user interfaces, you're going to have markup for HTML, that's going to be for the web, and then you're going to have markup for NativeScript that's XML. But all your business logic, right?
所有实际 UI 的更新，反之亦然。这被称为渲染器。所以 NativeScript 所做的是，NativeScript 进来并说，好吧，浏览器以前是渲染器，现在我是渲染器。所以你实际上可以——我们已经做到了——我们正在开发工具，允许你创建一个同时针对 Web 和移动端的应用程序。现在，区别在于你正在构建两个不同的用户界面，你将拥有 HTML 标记，那是给 Web 用的，然后你将拥有 NativeScript 的标记，那是 XML。但你所有的业务逻辑，对吧？
All your models, all your data, all your services layer where you're calling your API, all of that is normalized into a set of code that you can use across those two projects. Gotcha. Do you expect them to unify the markups? Because there's something, there's like Bootcamp, for example, which makes it so that, you know, as unify the markups because there's something there's like boot camp for example which which makes it so that you know as you resize the window your app your website still
你所有的模型、所有的数据、你调用 API 的所有服务层，所有这些都被标准化为一套可以在这两个项目中使用的代码。明白了。你期望他们统一标记语言吗？因为有些东西，比如 Bootcamp，它使得，你知道，统一标记语言，因为有些东西，比如 Bootcamp，它使得，你知道，当你调整窗口大小时，你的应用、你的网站仍然
looks reasonable and so i could imagine with boot camp um you know maybe it's it's some kind of markup language meta markup language or something that would turn into HTML and XML. I guess that's probably overkill. No, there's actually a project out there for NativeScript that does that. I think it's called NativeScript HTML. And so yeah, there's a lot of different people thinking in a lot of different directions. I think that we
看起来很合理，所以我可以想象使用 Bootcamp……你知道，也许它是一种标记语言，元标记语言或类似的东西，可以转换成 HTML 和 XML。我想那可能有点大材小用了。不，实际上有一个 NativeScript 的项目可以做到这一点。我想它叫 NativeScript HTML。所以是的，有很多不同的人在从很多不同的方向思考。我认为我们
have to try all these different things and figure out which of these things actually solves a problem for developers. Which one of these is the easiest to use and isn't just cool but is actually useful? Yeah, that makes sense. It's sort of this delicate balance between, you know, like polishing something, which usually means understanding it in depth and moving quickly. And that seems to be sort of the cornerstone behind this whole thing.
必须尝试所有这些不同的东西，并找出哪些东西真正解决了开发者的痛点。哪一个最容易使用，而且不仅仅是看起来很酷，而是真正有用？是的，这很有道理。这是一种微妙的平衡，你知道，就像打磨某样东西，这通常意味着深入理解它并快速行动。这似乎是这一切背后的基石。
Yeah, we're sort of striking a fine balance, aren't we? There's like a pendulum that swings, and we're trying to desperately balance it in the right spot and stop it from moving so we can all catch up and be current on technology. But alas, I don't know that that will ever happen nice do you see a uh i mean so there was a lot of apps that were ios only um you know early on and now there's just a ton of pressure to uh make apps for android like prisma is a good example prisma made an ios app and you know a lot of these magazines you know newsweek and other people you know the first thing they said one of the first things they said is they don't have an Android app yet. And so if you're a successful app developer, you get a lot of external pressure to support Android. Do you think that you see like an
是的，我们正在达成一种微妙的平衡，不是吗？就像一个摆动的钟摆，我们正拼命试图把它平衡在正确的位置，并阻止它移动，这样我们所有人都能赶上并掌握最新的技术。但唉，我不知道那是否会发生。不错，你是否看到一个……我的意思是，早期有很多应用是 iOS 独占的，现在有巨大的压力要为 Android 制作应用，比如 Prisma 就是一个很好的例子，Prisma 制作了一个 iOS 应用，你知道，很多杂志，比如《新闻周刊》和其他人，他们说的第一件事就是他们还没有 Android 应用。所以如果你是一个成功的应用开发者，你会面临很大的外部压力来支持 Android。你认为你看到了一个
up-and-coming os or do you think it'll it'll just stick with these two forever or for at least the next few years i mean i think the only challenger out there right now would be the universal windows platform or the uwp which is the same operating system on all devices, phones, tablets, desktops. Unfortunately, though, the mobile market is just dominated by two players. I mean, it's just dominated. And so, I mean, I don't see anyone waiting in the wings. I don't see any up-and-comers there. Yeah, it seems like a losing market because once Android became open source,
有前途的操作系统，还是你认为它会永远停留在这两个平台上，或者至少在未来几年内？我的意思是，我认为目前唯一的挑战者是通用 Windows 平台（UWP），它在所有设备（手机、平板电脑、桌面）上都是同一个操作系统。然而不幸的是，移动市场被两个玩家主导了。我的意思是，它完全被主导了。所以，我的意思是，我没看到有人在等待机会。我没看到任何后起之秀。是的，这看起来是一个失败的市场，因为一旦 Android 开源，
it really torpedoed. I remember when Android first came out, Microsoft Windows Mobile was a big thing, and I think Nokia had something. And then when Android came out open source and there was no licensing fee, they just completely torpedoed all of those companies' business models. And I just don't see how anyone could compete with that. Yeah, it's really hard.
它真的就彻底摧毁了。我记得 Android 刚出来的时候，微软 Windows Mobile 是个大东西，我想诺基亚也有一些东西。然后当 Android 开源且没有许可费时，他们就彻底摧毁了所有这些公司的商业模式。我实在看不出还有谁能与之竞争。是的，这真的很难。
And I think that for developers, we're very married to our platforms. So I have an iPhone. So when I build apps, I build iOS apps because I assume that everyone uses an iPhone because why would you not? But that's not the case, right? And so, you know, you're missing out on like at least half, maybe more. I think Android has even more of the market share now depending upon especially which market you're going into.
而且我认为对于开发者来说，我们非常忠于我们的平台。所以我有一部 iPhone。所以当我构建应用时，我构建 iOS 应用，因为我假设每个人都用 iPhone，因为为什么不呢？但事实并非如此，对吧？所以，你知道，你错过了至少一半，甚至更多。我认为 Android 现在拥有更多的市场份额，具体取决于你进入的市场。
So especially if you're going into developing markets, that's like an all Android market. Right, definitely. So, you know, it's having both platforms covered is almost table stakes. Yep. Almost table stakes. I don't want to turn this into a... Yeah, sorry.
所以特别是如果你进入发展中市场，那几乎全是 Android 市场。没错，绝对是。所以，你知道，覆盖两个平台几乎是入场券。是的。几乎是入场券。我不想把这变成一个……是的，抱歉。
I don't want to turn it into a giant political discussion. But I mean, one of the things when I read people's kind of... I know you call them postmortems, but after an app gets released and they talk about this... I've seen several fairly high-profile ones where people did release an Android app, and not for something where you're a company that needs to get the app out in front of people,
我不想把它变成一场宏大的政治讨论。但我的意思是，当我阅读人们的……我知道你们称之为“尸检报告”，也就是在应用发布后，他们谈论这些……我见过几个相当高调的案例，人们确实发布了安卓应用，而且不是那种公司为了让应用触达用户而发布的情况，
but, you know, like a premium app that you're trying to sell. And what they're saying is that even though Android has a ton more users, the amount of spend from Android users is just far lower than iOS. So even though Android may dominate numbers-wise, dollars-wise, iOS seems to dominate from most of the information I've seen. I agree. I've seen those stats as well. I think one of the more concerning stats that I've seen is this one where building an app and actually being able to monetize that on either platform is incredibly difficult now.
而是像那种你试图销售的付费应用。他们所说的是，尽管安卓用户多得多，但安卓用户的消费额远低于 iOS。所以尽管安卓在数量上可能占主导地位，但从我看到的大多数信息来看，在金额上，iOS 似乎占据主导地位。我同意。我也看过那些统计数据。我认为我看到的最令人担忧的统计数据之一是，现在在任何平台上构建应用并真正实现盈利都变得极其困难。
I mean, incredibly difficult. So NativeScript is primarily used in the enterprise, right? The enterprise is still building native apps that are very much internal apps, or they're B2B apps. They're built for their partners and customers. And they're distributing those apps via internal app stores. They're managing those apps, but they're still building the apps the same way that we built desktop apps back in the 90s. This is that new scenario just playing out now. As far as people building consumer apps, I mean, that's just got to be the bravest thing you can do as a startup is build a mobile app. Because man, is that an uphill climb? Yeah. And I mean, trying to do SEO is a total nightmare. As you said, I mean, personally, if I want to find an app, I have to go to Google, look up the app I want. And now I think actually Google has some deep integration with the App Store where you can install it straight from Google.
我的意思是，极其困难。所以 NativeScript 主要用于企业级开发，对吧？企业仍然在构建非常内部化的原生应用，或者是 B2B 应用。它们是为合作伙伴和客户构建的。他们通过内部应用商店分发这些应用。他们管理着这些应用，但他们构建应用的方式仍然和我们在 90 年代构建桌面应用的方式一样。这正是现在正在上演的新场景。至于那些构建消费类应用的人，我的意思是，作为初创公司，构建移动应用绝对是你所能做的最勇敢的事情。因为天哪，那真是一条艰难的爬坡路。是的。而且，尝试做 SEO 简直是一场噩梦。正如你所说，我个人如果想找一个应用，我必须去谷歌搜索我想要的应用。现在我想谷歌实际上与应用商店有很深的集成，你可以直接从谷歌安装它。
But yeah, I mean, the App Store itself, it's almost impossible to make your app popular oh yeah the app stores are are not good for you know searchability and and finding things even when you know the name of an app i don't know if you guys have ever seen this before where you like go in and you're like i know the name of the app and you punch it in but you don't punch it in right and it's nowhere to be found you're like come on come i know it's here you couldn't i i wrote instagram and left out the g and you couldn't figure that out come on give me a break exactly um so this is kind of a bit off topic but if you um if you want to do development like if you want to launch your app on both android and ios um do you have to be using a mac you Or can you use a Windows or Linux machine and develop for iOS?
但确实，应用商店本身，想要让你的应用受欢迎几乎是不可能的。哦，是的，应用商店在可搜索性和发现内容方面做得并不好，即使你知道应用的名字。我不知道你们是否遇到过这种情况，就是你进去之后，心想“我知道这个应用的名字”，然后你把它输进去，但你输错了，结果什么都找不到。你会想“拜托，我知道它就在这儿”。我写 Instagram 时漏掉了一个 g，结果你们竟然没能识别出来，拜托，饶了我吧。没错。嗯，这有点跑题了，但如果你想进行开发，比如你想在安卓和 iOS 上同时发布应用，你必须使用 Mac 吗？还是你可以使用 Windows 或 Linux 机器来为 iOS 开发？
Yeah, you can. And so shameless plug here, but what we sell, part of the products and the tooling that we sell is something called the Telerik platform, which allows you to build your apps on Windows. And then what we do is we basically outsource the build portion of that
是的，你可以。这里做一个无耻的广告，我们销售的产品和工具中，有一部分叫做 Telerik 平台，它允许你在 Windows 上构建应用。然后我们所做的是，基本上将构建部分外包出去，
or let you outsource it to a networked machine. So you basically send your build across the wire to a build machine, which then sends it back to you. So that's one of the ways that you can do that on Windows. We're not the only ones that do that. There's a couple of different others. Xamarin does that, PhoneGap does that. But yeah, it is definitely possible as long as you have a networked Mac in some way, shape,
或者让你将其外包给联网的机器。所以你基本上是通过网络将你的构建任务发送到一台构建机器上，然后它再发回给你。所以这是你在 Windows 上实现这一目标的方法之一。我们并不是唯一这样做的人。还有其他几家。Xamarin 这样做，PhoneGap 也这样做。但确实，只要你以某种形式拥有联网的 Mac，这绝对是可能的，
or form, or in our case, where we basically license you the ability to do that via our build services. Gotcha. So it goes to the cloud, it gets built, and then the app comes back. And then I guess it goes from your computer to your Windows machine to the phone, runs on your phone, but I'm assuming you can't really debug it or anything like that. Well, yes, debugging is a lot harder, but one of the ways that we get around that is we're looking at things like cloud emulators
或者像我们这种情况，我们基本上是通过我们的构建服务授权你这样做。明白了。所以它进入云端，完成构建，然后应用再回来。然后我想它会从你的电脑，也就是 Windows 机器传到手机上，在你的手机上运行，但我假设你无法真正调试它之类的。嗯，是的，调试要困难得多，但我们绕过这个问题的方法之一是研究云模拟器，
where basically everything is running in the cloud, and then your emulator runs in the cloud, and then you can debug as well, right? So we're just basically going to pipe you the whole experience so that you don't have to download or install anything. Because I don't know if you guys have ever tried to install the Android SDK before, but not only is it like six gigs,
基本上所有东西都在云端运行，然后你的模拟器也在云端运行，这样你也可以进行调试，对吧？所以我们基本上只是要把整个体验通过管道传给你，这样你就不用下载或安装任何东西了。因为我不知道你们是否曾经尝试过安装安卓 SDK，它不仅有六个 G 那么大，
but it's also a frigging nightmare. So just getting the native SDK set up is a huge feat. And you haven't even built anything. You just got it to run. And I think that as developer tools companies, we have got to get rid of that or people are not going to put up with that much longer. Yeah, that sounds terrible.
而且简直是一场噩梦。所以仅仅是配置好原生 SDK 就是一项巨大的工程。而且你甚至还没开始构建任何东西。你只是让它运行起来了。我认为作为开发者工具公司，我们必须摆脱这种情况，否则人们不会再忍受那么久了。是的，那听起来太糟糕了。
I'm surprised it isn't as easy as just installing Xcode, but I've never done it, so I don't know what the reason is for that complexity. Well, you know, more open systems, so more variables. Yeah, that makes sense. There's probably a lot of configuration and all that. So how does NativeScript, what's the relationship between NativeScript
我很惊讶它不像安装 Xcode 那么简单，但我从没做过，所以我不知道这种复杂性的原因是什么。嗯，你知道，系统越开放，变量就越多。是的，这说得通。可能有很多配置之类的东西。那么 NativeScript 是什么样的，NativeScript 与 Xcode 或 Android Development Studio 这些 IDE 之间的关系是什么？我的意思是，它们是协同工作的吗？你们有自己的 IDE 吗？这是怎么运作的？嗯，NativeScript 是一个命令行工具。所以它在终端中运行，或者在……Windows 上叫什么来着？命令行，命令提示符，对吧？
and these IDEs like Xcode or the Android Development Studio? I mean, do they work in tandem? Do you have your own IDE? Like, how does that work? Well, NativeScript is a command line tool. So it runs in the terminal or it runs on the, what is it called on Windows? Command line, command prompts, right?
CMD，命令提示符。Windows 上是这么叫的吗？我想，命令提示符。对吧？CMD 命令提示符。Windows 上是这么叫的吗？我想，是的，我想它仍然叫命令提示符。但我明白了，是的，它完全基于 JavaScript，所以你并不真正需要 Xcode，因为你并不是真的在用 Objective-C 编码。不，没错。
CMD, command prompts. Is that what it's called on Windows? I think, Command prompts. Right? CMD command prompts. Is that what it's called on Windows? I think, yeah, I think it's called command prompts still. But I see, yeah, so it's all on JavaScript so you don't really need Xcode per se because you're not really coding in Objective-C. No, correct.
它是一个 Node 工具。当你安装 NativeScript 时，只需运行 npm install nativescript -g，它就会安装 NativeScript，对吧？它在 Node 上运行。现在，它也要求你拥有，比如如果你在 Mac 上，需要安装 Xcode 和安卓 SDK。
It's a Node tool. When you install NativeScript, it's just npm install nativescript-g which installs NativeScript, right? And it runs on Node. Now, it also requires you to have, like if you're on a Mac, like Xcode and the Android SDK is installed.
虽然如果你没有它们，它会尝试为你下载并安装它们，或者根据苹果或谷歌对这些 SDK 的许可协议，引导你到可以获取它们的网站。明白了。所以，一旦你完成了所有设置，是的，它就是一个运行该程序的 Node 模块。既然如此，
Although if you don't have them, it will attempt to pull them down and install them for you on your machine via an installable or direct you to the site where you can get those, depending upon what the license agreements are for those SDKs from Apple or Google. Gotcha. So, so once you have all that set up, yes, it's a node, it's a node module that runs that. So that being the case,
我们提供了与 Visual Studio Code 的开箱即用集成。那是我们首选的 IDE。那是我们使用的工具。NativeScript 就是在其中开发的，因为我们使用 TypeScript。而 Visual Studio Code 对 TypeScript 有着极好的支持。然而，有……是的，我们做过一期关于 TypeScript 的节目，但对于还没听过的人来说，它基本上是一种独立的语言，算是 JavaScript 的超集，它为你提供了类型安全或类型推断，这非常重要。
we provide integration out of the box with Visual Studio Code. That's our preferred IDE. That's the one that we use. That's what NativeScript is developed in because we use TypeScript. And Visual Studio Code has fantastic support for TypeScript. However, there's... Yeah, we did a show on TypeScript, but for people who didn't listen to it yet, it's basically a separate language that's sort of a superset of JavaScript, and it gives you type safety or type inferencing, which is really important.
然后它会转译成 JavaScript。所以最终你得到的仍然是 JavaScript。而且这些 JavaScript 实际上是可读的。它不像 LLVM 那样，从 TypeScript 变成完全无法理解的东西。所以你从 TypeScript 得到了完全可读的 JavaScript。但是，如果在这个过程中，TypeScript 编译器发现你试图将一个字符串赋值给一个整数，它可以警告你，这样它就不会变成运行时错误。是的，绝对是。而且因为它具有强类型，它提供了 IntelliSense。
And then it then transpiles to JavaScript. So you still have JavaScript in the end. And the JavaScript is actually readable. It's not like LLVM or something where you go from TypeScript to total nonsense. So you go from TypeScript to totally readable JavaScript. But if through that process, the TypeScript compiler transpiler learns that you've tried to set a string to an int, it can warn you so that doesn't become a runtime error. Yeah, absolutely. And because it is strongly typed, it provides IntelliSense.
我们称之为 IDE 内部的 IntelliSense。哦，不错。你可以想象一下，当你使用 NativeScript 时，它处理的是庞大的原生 SDK，iOS 的 API 表面积非常巨大，安卓也是如此，所以你要么不断地去查阅文档，要么如果你使用 TypeScript，你只需输入方法或属性的前几个字母，
We'll call that IntelliSense inside of the IDE. Oh, nice. Which if you can imagine when you have NativeScript, scripts which is dealing with native SDKs which are huge the API surface of iOS is enormous and same with Android so you can either constantly go to the docs and look that stuff up or if you're using TypeScript you can just type out the first
点击点号，然后滚动浏览可用属性或方法的列表，文档就在 IDE 中你需要的地方。这就是 TypeScript 真正酷的地方。是的。是的，太棒了。
part of the method or property hit dot and then scroll through the list of available properties or methods with the documentation right in the IDE where you need it. That's the really cool thing with TypeScript. Yeah. Yeah, that's awesome.
所以我猜你们提供了一个，我猜你们，哦，你们甚至不需要提供任何东西，因为微软已经通过 TypeScript 实现了 IntelliSense，所以你们只需要 API。嗯，我们为 iOS 和安卓提供了定义。对，这说得通。是的，所以当你创建一个新项目时，我们可以为你提供 iOS 和安卓的定义。对。所以当你创建一个新项目时，我们可以为你提供 iOS 和安卓的定义，
So I guess you provide like a, I guess you, oh, you don't even really have to provide anything because Microsoft already does the IntelliSense with TypeScript, so you just have the API. Well, we ship definitions for iOS and Android. Right, that makes sense. Yeah, so when you create a new project, we can give you definitions for iOS and Android. Right. So when you create a new project, we can give you definitions for iOS and Android
它们基本上告诉 TypeScript，嘿，这里有所有可用的不同方法、子方法以及这些东西是如何关联的。酷。是的，这太棒了。我实际上，这让我想要去构建另一个应用，希望比我的安卓 2.0 应用或无论那是什么东西要好。你应该再构建一个“选数字”应用。
that basically tell TypeScript, hey, here's all the different methods that are available and submethods and how these things relate. Cool. Yeah, this is awesome. I actually, this is making me want to go and build another app that is hopefully better than my Android 2.0 app or whatever it was. Should build another pick a number app.
不，它是，那是什么？随机触发问题。是的，是的。一定要做一些，再做一个酒吧问答应用。是的。我的意思是，使用 NativeScript，我实际上已经能够构建带有地图和各种东西的真实应用了。所以如果我能做到，任何人都能做到。我向你保证这一点。酷。所以如果有人想尝试 NativeScript，它是怎么运作的？
No, it was, what was it? Random trigger question. Yeah, yeah. Definitely do some, make another bar trivia app. Yeah. I mean, with NativeScript, I've actually been able to build actual apps with maps and all sorts of stuff. So if I can do it, anyone can do it. I promise you that much. Cool. So if someone wants to try NativeScript, how does that work?
它是开源的吗？他们可以直接去下载吗？他们需要购买吗？你们有学生许可证吗？那个过程是什么样的？NativeScript 从头到尾完全开源，全部都是。所以你只需访问 nativescript.org，那里有一个大按钮写着“开始使用”，你点击那个按钮，它就会带你进入一个指南，引导你构建一个能够进行身份验证和登录的应用，帮助你跟踪购物清单，并使用那些酷炫的侧滑栏之一，
Is it open source? Can they just go and download it? Do they buy it? Do you have a student license? What's sort of that process like? NativeScript is fully open source from front to back, all of it. So you just go to nativescript.org and there's a big button that says get started and you click on that button and then it'll take you to a guide and walk you through building an application that does authentication and sign in and helps you track a list of groceries and use one of those cool slide out bars, uh,
侧面的侧滑菜单，并在过程中教你 NativeScript 的基础知识。所以如果你完成了那个入门指南，你就会成为一名 NativeScript 的发烧友。酷。
slide out menus on the side, uh, and teaches you the fundamentals of native script along the way. So if you get all the way through that, getting started guide, you will be, you will be a native script aficionado. Cool.
是的。如果有人这样做了，请告诉我们。嗯，你知道，听到一些成功故事之类的总是很好的，我们偶尔会收到一封邮件，来自尝试过我们在节目中谈论过的内容的人，这总是非常令人满足。这些实际上是最好的邮件，所以如果你尝试了 Burke 的教程并且做出了一个很棒的购物应用，一定要给我们发邮件，让我们知道，我们下次会在节目中提到你。是的，那太棒了。而且我们实际上，当你到达结尾时，底部有一个按钮，上面写着“嘿，你做到了”，
Yeah. And if anyone does that, let us know. Um, uh, you know, it's always good to hear, uh,
发推文分享它，它基本上会预先写好一条充满表情符号的推文，写着“我完成了 NativeScript 入门指南”，所以我们经常看到这种情况，每次看到它，团队里的工程师们都会欢呼。太棒了。非常酷。
you know, kind of success stories and things like that every now and then we get an email from someone who's tried something that we've talked about in the show and it's always really satisfying those are actually the best emails so if you've tried Burke's tutorial and you have
你们有一个，我们实际上有一个 Webhook，我不记得了。哦，是当有人破坏了构建的时候。所以当持续集成系统检测到有人破坏了构建的主分支时，这个机器人，比如 LED 灯会变红，然后它就开始大叫。是的。我以前见过类似的东西。每次有人完成教程，就像 Burke 办公室里的一个机器人
an awesome grocery app definitely send us an email, let us know and we'll give you a shout out on the air next time yeah that'd be awesome and we actually there's like a button at the bottom when you get to the end and it's like hey you did it
把篮球投进篮筐之类的。所以你会让他非常高兴。是的，没错。是的。我们喜欢它。酷。好吧，非常感谢你来到节目。我一定会尝试
tweet about it and it basically like pre-composes a tweet that's full of emoji and says like I completed the native script getting started guide so we see that all the time and every time we see it there's like this you know, big cheer from the team, the engineers. Awesome. Very cool.
这个教程。我觉得它很酷。如果外面有人想制作一个 Web 应用，特别是正如我们所说的，制作 iOS 和安卓版本非常重要。即使你是为你的朋友、你的高中、你的大学项目制作它，当你能把你的应用交给某人，
Do you have a, we actually had a webhook for, I don't remember. Oh, it was when someone broke the build. So when the continuous integration system detected that, that someone had broken the master branch of the build, this robot, like the LED lights turned red and it started yelling. Yep. I've seen stuff like that before. Every time someone completes a tutorial, like a robot at Burke's office
而他们有 100% 的机会可以使用它，而不是 50-50 的机会，那会更有成就感。所以去看看这个吧。再次感谢你来到节目。是的，绝对的。最后还有一件事，让我指出，
shoots a basketball in a basketball hoop or something. So you'll make him very happy. Yes, that's right. Yep. We love it. Cool. Well, thank you so much for coming on the show. I'm definitely going to try
在 nativescript.org 网站上，我想是在资源栏目下。我们有一个 Slack 频道，那里有成千上万的开发者聚在一起，互相倾诉并互相帮助。所以这真的非常非常酷。所以如果你开始使用并遇到了困难，去看看 Slack 频道。
this tutorial. I think it's pretty cool. And if anyone out there wants to make a web app, especially as we said, so important that you make it iOS and Android. Even if you're making it for your friends, for your high school, for a college project, it's so much more satisfying when you can give your app
哦，非常酷。所以他们去 nativescript.org，然后有一个链接，我想是去 Slack 的。是的，我想是在资源栏目下。那是顶部的一个菜单项。酷。是的，很好的资源。非常感谢。我们回头再聊。
to someone and there's not a 50-50 chance that they can use it. There's 100% chance that they could use it. So check this out. And thanks again for being on the show. Yeah, absolutely. And just one last thing, let me just point out that
哦，除了 NativeScript，你还有什么想推广的吗？Progress 有什么想推广的吗？哦，哇。天哪，什么都可以？我可以推广任何东西吗？你可以推广任何你想推广的东西。哇。好吧，如果你正在进行 Web 开发，
on that nativescript.org site, I think it's under resources. We have a Slack channel there where there's thousands of developers just hang out and commiserate and help each other. So it's really, really cool. So if you get started and you get stuck, check out the Slack channel.
在 nativescript.org 网站上，我想是在资源页面下。我们有一个 Slack 频道，那里有成千上万的开发者聚在一起交流心得、互相帮助。这真的很棒。所以如果你开始使用并遇到了困难，去看看那个 Slack 频道吧。
Oh, very cool. So they go to nativescript.org and then there's a link, I guess, to the Slack. Yeah, I think it's under resources. It's a menu item at the top. Cool. Yeah, good resource. Thank you so much. And we will catch you later.
哦，太酷了。所以他们去 nativescript.org，然后那里有一个链接指向 Slack，对吧？是的，我想是在资源菜单下。那是顶部的一个菜单项。酷。是的，很好的资源。非常感谢。我们稍后再聊。
Oh, do you have anything you want to plug other than native script? Anything that Progress wants to plug? Oh, wow. Geez, anything? I can plug anything at all? You can plug anything you want. Wow. Well, if you're doing web development,
哦，除了 NativeScript，你还有什么想推广的吗？Progress 公司有什么想推广的吗？哦，哇。天哪，什么都可以吗？我可以推广任何东西吗？你可以推广任何你想推广的东西。哇。好吧，如果你正在进行网页开发，
Progress also makes a tool called Kendo UI, if you're doing web development, Procureus also makes a tool called Kendo UI, which is a web UI framework. And we've just gotten started on rebuilding that from the ground up for Angular 2. And we're really super proud of it. It's in beta. It's going to be in RC in January. So you can check that out at kendoui.com.
Progress 还制作了一个名为 Kendo UI 的工具，如果你在进行 Web 开发，Progress 也制作了一个名为 Kendo UI 的工具，它是一个 Web UI 框架。我们刚刚开始为 Angular 2 从零开始重建它。我们对此感到非常自豪。它目前处于测试阶段，一月份将进入候选发布版本（RC）。所以你可以在 kendoui.com 上查看它。
It's a free download. We'd love for you to use it and tell us what you think if you're into web development. Cool. Yeah, I will check that out. Cool. Thank you so much. All right.
它是免费下载的。如果你从事 Web 开发，我们非常希望你能使用它并告诉我们你的想法。太棒了。好的，我会去看看。太棒了。非常感谢。好的。
Thanks so much, guys. Have a good one. All right. Bye. So everyone out there, that was Burke. And it was an awesome episode. I learned so much. Patrick and I learned so much about NativeScript. A couple of
非常感谢，伙计们。祝你们过得愉快。好的。再见。各位听众，刚才那是 Burke。这是一期很棒的节目。我学到了很多。Patrick 和我学到了很多关于 NativeScript 的知识。关于
meta things. The t-shirt is, the straw poll is still going on. I'm talking to several t-shirt companies about that. Still trying to figure that part of it out, but they're definitely interested. We have over 100
一些元信息。T 恤的民意调查还在进行中。我正在和几家 T 恤公司谈这件事。还在努力弄清楚那部分，但他们绝对感兴趣。我们有超过 100 件
t-shirts, so everyone I talk to is saying, oh, you definitely should buy in bulk and things like that, which is awesome. That's good news. And so they're willing to kind of work with us. Thanks again for supporting us on Patreon, on Amazon, all of that. And we'll catch you guys next time. The intro music is Axo by biner pilot programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute
T 恤的需求，所以我交谈过的每个人都说，哦，你绝对应该批量购买之类的，这太棒了。这是个好消息。所以他们愿意和我们合作。再次感谢你们在 Patreon、亚马逊上对我们的支持，以及所有的一切。我们下次再见。片头音乐是 biner pilot 的 Axo，Programming Throwdown 是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发的，你可以自由分享、复制、分发
transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide attribution to patrick and i and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
传播作品，进行重混、改编作品，但你必须注明我和 Patrick 的署名，并以相同方式共享。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。